when my two most believes the war is
really over it's hard being a writer
well my first book sold only how many
copies one zero worldwide very fast in
my name is Dorsey Adams I am part of a
book club the Guernsey literary and
potato peel pyar society founded by
Elizabeth McKenna our Friday night book
club became a refuge to us during the
occupation by the Chairman's the daily
finally I'll have something serious to
write real writer
don't you see us
we're expecting you so happy Thank You
mr. Adams over yet to meet it you've
conjured him hello hello I'd like very
much to write about you this society a
new founder Elizabeth McKenna I'm so
looking forward to meeting her you won't
be meeting her there's more to that
story than they'd like to let on what
happened it's not my story to tell
really
Elizabeth you must do the same
you have I've seen things I never
thought could happen happen I lost
people too if you'd let me I'd like to
try and help you are not what I expected
how did you imagine me mr. Adams suppose
it's possible for us to already belong
to someone before we've met them
I feel keenly how your life has changed
the arc of my own forever
[Music]
these books do have the power to bring
people together this one may work it's
magic
you get to have the full experience
potato filled pie the Ganzi literary and
potato peel pie society crack that's
quite enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you